very much what Reproductive Rights do
men have
[Music]
I feel like
well I don't know maybe you guys can
answer this I feel like a lot of the
time when a girl gets pregnant and it's
because a lot of guys are like get
accidentally get their situation ships
pregnant they'll say to the girl can you
get an abortion I don't want this or
they'll be cheating on the wife and get
an abortion all of those things so I
feel like you're saying it's it's not
it's not fair that oh that a woman can
get an abortion but when I feel like in
the UK the majority of the time it's a
man that wants to have an abortion so
how is it an accident when women know
when we're ovulating and women can
choose whether or not to be on birth
control most women don't know when
they're ovulating because my storm
window trackers and they're not always
reliable but wouldn't that put the power
in women's hand like you can get an IUD
that's 99 effective you can take a plan
B you can get the do the pills you can
do the thing in your arms but that sort
of things that modify your body they're
all adding hormones a lot of people get
really bad side effects from from using
those questions you can you can you can
require that the men that you sleep with
wear a condom
but I'm saying like like women have all
the power in this situation and if it
doesn't all doesn't work out we can go
get an abortion so what Reproductive
Rights do men have using a condom that's
it that's not right so so I'm saying
it's not even it's not equal so did you
listen to how many things Pearl listed
and how many and how many reasons you
had as to why that wasn't viable so is
that you've got the IUD no don't want
that hormones okay so you've got
um what 41 types of birth control
they're all the same thing in different
forms basically so you've got 41 ways
then you have then you have the hormones
on the copper one I'm just gonna then
you have the morning after pill right
and then you have the right after
negating all of those things to just say
to the guy
child support time but when they came
out when they were doing new
um like they're doing research at the
moment for male contraception that
included like a tablet and also a gel a
lot of men like if you went to social
media and looked at the postman were
like I'm not taking tablets imagine a
girl tells me to take my birth control
the same way that yeah the same way you
just did when we brought up birth
control
but I'm saying like I just brought this
up now and your first response was but
the side effects so kind of the same way
that but we don't know the side effects
of the men's one we don't even know if
it's a hormone thing or what okay but
you see the double stick like you just
did the same thing let's say I genuinely
don't see it let's see I'll take the
pill I'll take the pill
you're barely willing to deal with my BS
just as it is would you be able to deal
with my BS if my hormones went out of
whacking
you be a woman mate
this just goes down to a pure lack of
accountability
I think
women should be more aware if if they're
not already that they are The
Gatekeepers of every single child
vast majority of the time for the very
few exceptions I'm not going to mention
for the algorithm
they are The Gatekeepers for every child
they bear so this just goes down purely
to accountability of who the men they
are choosing and the foundation that
they want to bring a child into this
world the reason why we live in this
Society is because women are refusing to
take accountability feminism is on the
rise and marriage is under decline
if every woman bound together and said
we are not having sex unless you get
married what do you think men are gonna
do
they are going to the shop to get a ring
they are The Gatekeepers of sex they are
The Gatekeepers of children to bear in
this Society so we can talk as much and
make as many excuses till Kingdom Come
unless women take accountability for the
mistakes that do happen it's not going
to change but marriage isn't even the
way it falls anymore because women leave
women women leave they do live but again
that I've got my own view on marriage I
am myself but I I would always Advocate
when it comes speaking on the subject of
Father a fatherhood that for men to get
their stuff together men have to get
their stuff together to be the type of
woman because hypergamy is on the rise
the criteria for a man is getting less
and less and less this is this is this
is the reason why women refuse to settle
you get a woman in her 40s she could
have settled in her 20s but she's
looking for Superman and Clark Kent at
the same time that man don't exist you
know there's a book there's a Stanford
University in Euro Bowl which is
neuroscience it's called Robert sapolski
he wrote two books there are many but
behave and why zebras don't get ulcers
if you read these books it will tell you
where Life Starts and why life starts at
conception it it goes intricate details
into DNA Neuroscience neurotransmitters
look I'm not even neuroscientist I
barely go any education I read this book
because I understand it right it
explains me how to I'm going to treat my
child when he grows up because it talks
to you about child development and male
and female aggressions is intricate
details about our existence from
scientific perspective and if you read
it it's it's informative do you know
women are more likely to be violent
towards their children than men yeah one
beat me up all the time
I can believe that yeah
but you know why because because I I
think that's because men
your father they had the threat of
violence and you really have to do it
yeah yeah I remember my dad just looking
at me yeah there is a big difference
between my mom and dad looking at me
there is such an aura of a man yeah
that
they don't even need to speak to command
respect from children
when my dad when I did something wrong
my mom didn't even need to say she just
said I'm gay I'm gonna I'm gonna tell
you that and me and my brothers fixed up
I remember the first time I ever got
arrested the beat and I received made
sure I never did that again so
there is an authority figure in a mill
that cannot be exchanged for a woman
there is a way a man raises children
with authority and in love
that cannot be exchanged so I see why
we're like this I see why Society has
been like this I see why women are like
this even on the point of I know I touch
a lot on the boys but I can speak for uh
from a male a female perspective the
first woman
uh the first man a woman learns to love
and submit to is her father
because he's the only man who can look
at your door's eyes give you everything
you want and or anything in return he's
the only man who should be who will not
take anything back in return in pure
love so unless you have a good
understanding of
how to love a man and how a man should
love you you have no blueprint for love
so what do you think monogamy is the way
forward
monogamy yeah in my I'm a Christian so I
have a uh traditional mindset but I also
know the type of men
the type of men men want to be
they might it may not be consistent with
their world to be but for my personal
worldview yeah in terms of the fabric of
society it starts at home
some interesting because obviously you
practice polygamy right
um I'm in a monogamous relationship now
but by Nature I am polygamous
could you how
would be how would it be raising a child
in that type of environment
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible